Speaker 1: Let's continue following up on
the Ron DeSantis Martha's Vineyard immigrant
stunt.
One of the biggest I hesitate to call it a
confusion.
One of the biggest misstatements that's being
made about the entire thing is that the 50
or really 48 migrants who were flown to Martha's
Vineyard by Ron DeSantis on the tax dollars
of Floridians.
The claim is being made that they are here
illegally when that is actually not the case.
And the casual nature with with Republicans
are now claiming this is causing it to spread
like wildfire.
Those migrants were not here illegally.
I will explain that in a moment.
Here is Marco Rubio, just one example.
He was on Fox News yesterday or maybe this
was this morning.
This morning, in fact, saying these are folks
who are here illegally and of course, they
were not.
Speaker 2: Well, think about this.
People came into this country illegally violating
our laws.
No.
And the first thing they do is get lawyers
and use our laws to sue an elected governor.
Speaker 1: That's after they were lured, arguably
illegally, to get on a plane to send them
to Martha's Vineyard.
They are only now suing.
And we will talk about that lawsuit on the
bonus show.
Speaker 2: So state I mean, just think about
that.
They just got here.
They're not even here legally.
They didn't enter the country the proper way
and they're immediately in court demanding
rights and claims under our laws.
This is outrageous.
What other country in the world would that
even be allowed?
What other country in the world would even
tolerate that?
So I think this is you know, we have a this
is not immigration.
What we're seeing.
This is mass migration.
That's a very different thing.
And but to think about the fact that somebody
just came here illegally and within a week
they're in court and they have lawyers representing
them in court.
Speaker 1: Well, that's thanks to Ron DeSantis,
my friend.
Speaker 2: Suing the American government that
whose laws they just violated is unbelievable.
It's outrageous.
It angers me and it should anger everybody.
Speaker 1: So let's take this step by step.
The picture painted, but these Republicans
lie constantly.
The picture that Rubio is painting is a bunch
of illegal immigrants come to the U.S. They're
here illegally, and within days they're using
our court system to sue others, demanding
rights and demanding money that could not
be further from the truth.
First of all, as our friend Ana Casperson
tweeted, quote, Asylum seekers awaiting a
decision from immigration judges are not in
the U.S. illegally.
Also, Cubans like Marco Rubio, who benefited
from amnesty after the revolution.
Rubio's family, to be clear, should maybe
be more considerate and self-reflective when
weighing in on Venezuelan migrants.
So when you think of the story that Rubio
tells illegal immigrants for no reason, using
our courts to demand stuff, well, first of
all, they're not illegal immigrants.
When you are awaiting an asylum decision,
you are here legally in the sense that you
are pending a legal decision.
Now, asylum is discretionary, meaning sometimes
individuals.
Claim asylum and it is denied to them even
if they technically meet the definition of
refugees.
This has to do with the adjudication.
But when you do the right thing, you come
to the border, you request asylum.
It is awaiting a decision.
You are not here illegally.
So the first piece of Rubio story here illegally
for no reason.
Just filing lawsuits.
Actually, not here illegally.
The second part is the civil suit that has
now been filed by these migrants who are not
here illegally.
Has only been filed.
Because of what Ron DeSantis did.
Ron DeSantis is now under criminal investigation.
The state of Florida and the Dissenters administration
under criminal investigation for what is tantamount
to human trafficking.
They lied and deceived these migrants, lured
them to get on these planes, saying you're
going to go to Boston and get expedited legal
status.
And jobs didn't take them to Boston, took
them to Martha's Vineyard.
And that is why there is now a civil suit.
The story that Marco Rubio and Republicans
are telling doesn't have any truth to it.
I mean, they're mentioning that some of the
migrants are from Venezuela.
That's true.
Right.
I mean, if we want to find something that
is accurate.
So they are lying.
And we should be aware of that.
But unfortunately, the
lies
spread like wildfire.